hey guys it's justine i just wanted to
share with you this awesome interview
that i got a chance to do with mr
miyamoto who's the creator of mario and
a ton other of your favorite games
donkey kong zelda star fox pikmin and so
many more and acting as our translator
is bill trennan who is the director of
product marketing at nintendo this was
so much fun i hope you guys enjoy it and
let me know in the comments below what
your favorite nintendo game is and who
your favorite nintendo character is so i
mean first of all i think a lot of
people are really excited about the 30th
anniversary next year of super mario now
what do you want to tell us about that i
mean what is going to be something that
we can look forward to
seriously
is
yeah we wanted to do something to
celebrate the 30th anniversary of super
mario brothers and it just so happened
that we were working on mario maker so
the timing is is sort of
perfect
mario maker is a game that you know when
we were working on the original nes
mario super mario bros game 30 years ago
every level we had to first draw on
paper before we put it into the game
and it was a big process but with mario
maker it's a game where you can design
the level and as you're designing it you
can jump in and play and try it out
and so it's very fast and and very fun
so with mario maker of course we have
different skins for the game so there's
different uh graphics for art different
art styles for some of the different
mario games that are in there but what's
really fun about mario maker is that you
you know mario games are games where you
sort of you think and you try things out
when you play and with mario maker you
can do the same thing while you're
creating levels because you can you can
kind of look at the tools that you have
and say i wonder what happens if i
combine this enemy with this item and
see what happens
and there's a lot of things to discover
that way now do you think there's going
to be a huge community aspect to
something where people can play other
people's maps and everyone can play
online
yeah you'll be able to see you know what
happens when other people play your
course or when you play other people's
courses you know there will be you know
some popularity rankings for the most
popular courses and things like that so
there's a there's a lot on the community
side that you can listen to i should
start practicing my game developing here
i know
so yeah the basic premise is that you
know you'll be sitting down together
with somebody next to you your family or
a friend or something and and you'll
make something and let them try it but
of course we will have the the internet
ability to exchange courses as well
that's amazing now i mean 2015 is going
to be huge for you guys you show the
zelda trailer and that's such a huge
world and how is that going to be for
you guys to approach that as far as
gameplay
so yeah with zelda games what we've
always done is we've we've always tried
to make them a game where you you enter
this big world of hyrule and there's a
lot to explore and discover
but because of the hardware limitations
what we always had to do was segment off
each area and piece those segments
together in a way that made them feel
like a big world but now with the the
hardware capabilities of wii u
what we did was we first started by
saying well let's see what we can do if
we take a an entire world the size of
the world from twilight princess and
just try to make that as one area on the
game and you see that is one of those
games where people will go to complete a
certain mission and they end up doing 50
things along the way
foreign
yeah i mean there may even be times
where you forget what your goal is uh
because you're doing other things on the
side
and there may be times where you go into
one big long dungeon or there may be
times where you're headed to a dungeon
and you're doing other things along the
side but what we're trying to do is
design it in a way that
you don't necessarily have to sit down
and play it for a super long time but
kind of more matched to today's
lifestyle where you can you can think
for a little bit and say oh maybe i just
want to play for a little bit today and
do this one thing and get that done and
then take a break that's great now you
said this i believe if i heard this
correctly star fox will be out before
zelda so is that that is true
yes should be out before zelda we're
working hard to do that that's awesome
what do you want to tell me about the
new star fox
so with zelda we're using the gamepad uh
for the map features and it's very handy
for that but with star fox we're doing
something very different what we have on
the gamepad screen is is a cockpit view
and on the tv screen you've got a third
person it's more cinematic view
and as you're playing what you'll find
is that you'll you'll spend your time
looking back and forth between the two
and when you want to see the really cool
cinematic visuals as you're playing
you'll look up at the tv screen and when
you want to get really serious about
battling an enemy you'll look down at
the cockpit view
and so it gives a lot of different
perspectives and how you're able to kind
of switch between the two and play while
there's these beautiful cinematics going
on on the tv screen do you have a
favorite star fox character
i
and actually in my neighborhood near my
house there's uh there's a shrine that's
called fushimi nari and the uh the kind
of the the spirit of the shrine is takes
the shape of a fox wow
yeah and apparently it's the the most
popular spot in kyoto now with uh with
tourists from overseas that's awesome
well i know we're the first place i will
be visiting
so i think we have a little star fox
here so how do you see the amiibos
integrating into possibly zelda or star
fox or is that something we haven't
talked about yet
but uh but we do plan on doing something
so that people who have amiibo will get
some enjoyment out of having amiibo and
using them in those games yeah i love
even mario kart just being able to
unlock the skin suits and that's just
really fun
so now captain toad
treasure tracker has been really fun
it's such a cute game and i was
wondering is captain toad the same toad
from like the original
yeah actually when we made the original
toad
we didn't really
have in mind whether toad was a boy or a
girl
we just made the character toad and then
ever since toadette has
started appearing in games i think
people have come to take the impression
that toad was a boy because toadette was
a girl but uh obviously there's there's
lots of different toads that have been
in a lot of different games
so captain toad you know appeared in
super mario galaxy and there were other
toads in that game too but i think maybe
captain toad is really just a normal
toad who just happens to be wearing
those captain type clothes i see so what
is it about the treasures that they're
tracking why do they enjoy doing that so
much
so yeah i think you know they they
really represent the player in the game
so i think that they like treasure
hunting because players like treasure
hunting
and what's fun is the way that you you
rotate the little worlds around and you
see where the treasures are and it's
designed in a way where the person who's
playing is doing that with the gamepad
but the people sitting around you are
looking up the tv screen and giving you
advice while you're playing and giving
you tips on where to go so i'm a really
huge nintendo ds fan i've always been
such a huge fan of handheld gaming
dating back to the game boy i mean i had
the game boy light i had the magnifying
glass and the whole set yeah
this is a this is a special version of
the 3ds hardware that's available just
this this holiday
yes
so i put my me in here usually on my own
3ds i have me with a mario hat on but oh
man i don't have the mario hat yeah so
when you play do you mostly play in 3d
or do you play in 2d
i watch a little bit of both but you
know sometimes if i'm if i'm watching
the cinema scenes then i put those in 3d
oh
somebody's at my gate
oh my gosh i'm going to have to i need
to take a picture for instagram
this is this is exciting so how is it
too like with the internet
everything is so quick and so fast i
mean i used to sit by my mailbox waiting
for my nintendo power so that i could
get the latest news and that was the
only way because none of my friends
really played and were as into it as i
was so how has that change as far as
breaking news
taking user feedback and things like
that and when you're developing
it
yeah it's very fun for us but at the
same time it's hard because what it
means is we have to be better about
launching our products at the same time
worldwide that's true that is very true
so do you have anything coming up for
the ds that you can share with us
yesterday
we've already released a lot of games
for it like animal crossing this year we
had tomodachi life
there's yoshi's new island
pokemon just released and
and then next year we have a couple of
games that are
you know we have codename steam which is
much more kind of core gamer focused and
then of course majora's mask is coming
and that's one that we've spent quite a
bit of time touching up and improving
some of the rough edges i think that's
gonna be exciting especially the
throwback to the old game so i think
everyone's gonna be really excited about
that yes
is there anything else you want to tell
us about it
i have to ask
so 2015 super excited is there anything
else that you want to share with us to
the internet to my internet friends out
there
so yeah this is a wii u game the the
team that's making it is mostly the
younger members of our development teams
all together on in one group and it's it
feels like a very traditional nintendo
game the action feels really good in it
um but it's sort of a shooter and you'll
be able to play online but also they've
done they've put a lot of effort into
creating a very robust single-player
mode as well what's the whole
kind of world
i know
so there's
the characters there's these squid boys
and squid girls and what they do is they
spray ink around the the world and what
they can transform into squid and swim
through
their color of ink
and it feels really good to swim through
that and the the concept of the game is
that you're you're spraying ink to cover
the world and claim territory and so
it's essentially a game of trying to
claim more territory than the other team
so it's a kid's version first-person
shooter
yeah but it's also really fun for adults
too oh no
i mean obviously we're all gonna play
them too but it's a kid-friendly kind of
version
oh we do have a yoshi game coming it's a
yoshi that's made out of yarn it's
called yoshi's wooly world
and this is uh at its core is a simple
action game that anybody can play and so
how did yoshi get
well yeah the yoshi games originally we
always did the artwork in very pastel
colors
and so after we made the the uh kirby's
epic yarn game uh we thought you know
what the
the whole feel and style of yoshi would
match really well with sort of this yarn
motif um and so that's where it started
and so what we did was first we we made
an actual
yarn yoshi and started development from
there that's really cool i love sort of
taking that simplistic things like even
paper mario and turning it into sort of
a really fun game that people can enjoy
i've been making uh some animation as
well
and you can you can buy these uh from
the eshop and download them
oh wow
so there's there's three pikmin short
movies and then there's some additional
bonus content in there too these are so
cool
this is great
animations
you can watch the uh the pikmin short
movies and then you can press the
buttons to make different sounds to go
along with the movies
that's really cute
oh my gosh they're so adorable
so everybody in the world can see the
same thing
so he has one more of those special 3ds
hardware systems so this will be a
present for you today really
i might cry
thank you so much so so much oh my gosh
this is absolutely amazing
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did make sure you hit like and share it
with your other nintendo loving friends
and i will see you guys in my next video
bye just wanted to show you where the
nintendo 3ds ended up
its new home for the rest of its life